ご視聴ありがとうございました
ん
きたーーー 3人リッチの局面で余ったいいピンカフーピン
どない打つ気や師匠
いい
どうし
海が見たい
師 師匠
ど、どないしよったんや、いったい
すまん!
数腕甲短気、親で九万六千点です
つ、違い!別人だ
去年の手取りとはまるで違う
ど、どうしてこんなことに
ジュースはグレープフルーツでいい?
オッケーオッケー
おーっと年越しそば買わなあきまへんな
オラトンベイが大好きんだ
オレは何と言っても正当派だな
年末はカップ麺が品切れになりやすいんだよ
ゆずって
ほら、一気五百円
まあまあ、トヨタミ君
そんな安っぽいカップ麺なんか食べなくてもいいじゃない
アキラちゃん
もしかしてアキラちゃんの手作りそば食べさせてくれるとか
はい
ほら、パッケージ新しくなったのよ
お腹すいたらいっぱい食べてね
つくー
シンタロウくん今頃里帰りしてどうしてるかしら
どうせ麻雀だろ
うんあいつ他に何も能はないかんな
はあ今年一年何もいいことなかった
ああちょっと君
あ僕
サイオ君には図鑑の層が出ておる
君の来年の運勢をわしがこのギター占いで占って死んでよ
92年あなたはついてなかった だけど来年はうまくいく ああカッパギ カッパギ
そりゃからかわれたんだべおめえ
だせえやつ
あらもう食べちゃうの
さて食い終わったらサクサクいってみようか
もうやるの
あったりめえだおらおらバギメだバギメスだ
Developed by borni
よーし breakfast
うう、ドラゲリリーチや!
evening Relations pack
ハッタ、ハッタ、ハッタ ハッタ、ハッタ ハッタ ハッタ ハッタ ハッタ
これが出来る
2ピンが交互メシの小品機で それをトンタンキ
絶好の町や!
弱ー!そりゃちょっと異常に臆病ですやん!
そ、そうかな?
はい!現物よ!
キーピンが灯ってたら6400上がってましたや!
アホ!耳元でささやくさ!
やった!やった!これで三腕斬りリーチで高めキューピン!
リーチチュンイーペイコー5200のうっしっしーですがな
勝負よ
チュン持っとったらリーチ一発チュンでローピン当たれましたやん
チュン斬りのイーペイコーのみの手の玉なんて最低です
どうだ
その先輩も崩しで
かぁー。
わいは、師匠を見損ないまして。
今日からわいの師匠は、はやみさーん。
あの、見ないで。
そんな言いな言い方ないでしょ。
せっかく教えたの言うとんのに。
一人でできるもん。
こりゃあ、菅師匠。
こりゃまずおませ。
です。
ん
電波
ローン
ビーチ一発チャンタ三色
カネマンですやん
ズガーイ
ところで明智藩、町は何でした?
麺パンピン、高目三色の、りゃんうぅパーわん町だったのによ
なるほどな、あのチーピンも三わんも通っとるんですか
うるさーい
パン パン パンパン
リーチンだ
ウーピン トラ
おりぃ これは筋
ローン あんた 休めだ
リーチン 一発 タンヤオだ
箱下3200点
このウーシャンテンのハイパイが今年最後のハイパイとなるでしょう
今年最後のリーチ
ローン ハッピーニューイヤー
リーチ一発一通
リーチ トヨタミ 今年もよろしく頼むぜ
んどうしたトヨトミ
裏筋
どうし
あんなに危険パイをつぎすぎた
リーチ
ロン
ベンタンピンいいペーコ
つ、強い
去年の豊臣じゃない
ああ、いいそったらことねえめんさ
リーチ
さあ豊臣、サクサクオラに振り込むだよ
リーチね
裏筋
げ、どうすんだ
見物はある
しかし、あえて数腕を切った
なんで
ねえ、なんでなんで
それは
強気だからさ
まさきすじ
どうせ
すじ
三枚目
どうせ
現物リーチ
強気や
あの捨て牌に対してあの切り方
師匠は強気に生まれ変わりはったんや
あの占いが当たったんや
あんだ
ロー
リーチ、一発、タイヤ王!
けど師匠、明智徳川負けさしても、
早見さん沈めるまでは本物とは言えまへん。
タテホンイーシャンテン。
あった!
ウウソギリのカンパスオか、キウソギリのカンロウソウマチ。
でもローソーはドラこの局面では出ないわ
勝負しろだ
松戸チュンが場に一枚も切れてない
これは間違いない大惨言だ
これは切れないわ
ここはひとまず
ローン 初ドラ1
そ そんな手からドラを切るなんて
タコやんけ
夜明けだ
93年、豊臣観念の日が昇る!
えいっ!
ラーン!
三安侯ちゃんた本一八順と!
師匠!さすがワイの師匠や!
一人浮き、一人浮きですがな!
何?
なに?
やっす!マイナイチ!
あけち!マイナイチ!
あきな!マイナイチ!
トヨトミ!ぷがさん!
くそ!今日のところは完敗だぜ!
すごいわ!トヨトミ君!
ひとり勝ちか。終わってみるとむなしいもんだぜ。
トヨトミ、一人勝ちしたんだから何かおごってくんだ。正月だしよ。
ぼく、コーシのステーキ、小悪魔風ね。ほら、フォアグラの大盛り、卵つけてね。
私、3000円のコース。
わいも遠慮して、はやみさんと同じコースでええわ。
えっと、ぼく、ピクルスね。
かしこまりました。
こうして怒涛の1992年は終わり、劇的クライマックスへ向かってトヨトビの1993年は始まったのである。
スーパーズガン、最終回まであと3ヶ月。
諸君、明けましておめでとう!
リーチ
あんた40名でもうリーチだかよ
うん
おーし
あった
どうする
リアンピンを切って高めピンクイーペーコードライチでリーチをかけるか
リアンピンなら通るかも
いやまだ40名
現物いいピンギリのタイヤを目へ打ち回しても十分ある
何やってんだよ早く切れよ
トヨタミ
三層数層で三色目も狙える
だがそこまで手を送らせても大丈夫だろうか
トヨタミ
えええええええええええええええええ
ずがあああああああ
き、君たちやめなよ
なんだ?
だ、だめ!
もう一度行ってみぃ!
えいっ、いやあ
動物をいじめるのはよくない
- 貴様、貴様、貴様、貴様、貴様、貴様、貴様、貴様、貴様、貴様、貴様、貴様、貴様… 貴様、貴様…
もっかべして・・・
動物を虐待すると、WWFが黙ってないぞ!
何だと?
生意気言ってんじゃねぇんだ!
やっちまえ!
K、点で相手になんねぇ
口ほどにもない奴だ!
行こうぜ!
ありがとう。おかげで助かりました。
俺に竜宮城へご案内いわします。
さあ、お乗りください。
竜宮城って、たやひらめの舞踊りがあるっていう、あそこ?
そうです。
当然!華麗なお姫様なんかも!
当たり目です。
ラッキー!
お待たせしましたあれがリュウグウジョウです
それもきっとイタコダコはイカだ大したもんだ
そのジャンソーにはタコやイカがぎょうさんおったそうだ
おとひめさまお客さんお連れしました
いらっしゃいませ
私が当店のマネージャーを務めさせていただいている
乙姫です
おいしい
麻雀に勝ったらね
どっかで見たようなメンツだな
アニウンダウンダ言ってるんだ
サクサクやっとサクサク
このイカやタコに負けてたまるか
リーチ一発ドラドラバンバーン
マンガン程度で乙姫を諦められるか
ローン
メンホン一発シロドラドラバインワーン
まだまだ
ローン
メンタンドラドラ親手一万二千
はい玉手箱
こうして浦島太郎の髪は真っ白になってしまいましたとさ
あれ
わああんなに大きなイーピンが
そのイーピンの中からは玉のような赤ん坊が生まれた
ズガー!ズガー!ズガー!
そうしてズガン太郎という しょうもない名前をつけられたそうな
まったくただ飯ばっかり食い寄ってからに
あいつのせいで今月も赤字や
どっかに売り飛ばしてこようか
ええ
あの鬼退治に行ってお宝をたくさん持って帰ります
本間でっか師匠、期待とりまーす
戦利品、たんと持って帰れよな
ほれ、特製展望きみだんぼじゃ
こうして図鑑太郎は鬼退治の旅に出たそうな
そんな偉いかっこしてどこさん行くんだよ
なんかいいもん持ってんじゃんかん
え?
それ置いてけや、図鑑太郎
こ、これはおばあさんにもらった大切なきびだんごなんだぞ!
お前らなんかにやってたまるか!
じゃあ、こうしよう。
麻雀をやって俺たちが勝ったら、きびだんごをもらう。
僕が勝ったら、
俺たちが家来になって鬼ヶ島までついてってやろう。
いくらなんでも、こんな動物愛天には負けないだろう。
単品3食、おやまん。
ズガーン!
どうしよう、こんな動物に分けてたまるか。
ギャーン!
それ待ってたんだぜ。
メンチンピンフ、ドライチ、バイバーイ!
どこ?これなら通る?
ござる!
いっ、いっ、いっ、いっ、いっ、スーアンコウタンキー!
ズガーン!
じゃあ、きびだんご、いただきましょうかね。
だな、さっそくな。
ぼくにもせめて一口。
なんだおめえ、まだ息してたのか?
ほら、これでも食いな・・・
100点。
ズガーン!
こうしてズガン太郎は鬼ヶ島に行くことはなかったということじゃ。
赤ずかん!赤ずかん!
はーい!
お使い、お願いね。
はーい。
このパイを、病気のおばあさんのところに届けてちょうだい。
テム。
あ、あの、これ、パイはパイでも麻雀パイだよ、アキナちゃん。
つべこべ言わないの。それにあたしはお母さん。
そういうわけで、もうわかってると思うけど、
オラたちが、狼っつうわけだ。
すいません、新聞屋ですけど。
病気のおばあさん、いらっしゃいます?
はーい。
あら、かわいい子が三人も。
私ね、ちょうど暇だったのよ。
どうぞ、お入り。
うわあ、リッチ。
なんだ?
そのリッチは、土層見え見えじゃねえか。
あんたの読みも大したことないわね
そっか
じゃあ スーソー カン
リッシュ
出たー めんたん一発
グラブラン乗れ
おっと スーソー カンだから
8つ乗ったな 3倍マン
ジュガー
これでこの家もオラたちのもんだ
誰が来た?隠れろ
おばあちゃん、お見舞いに来たよ
おにごか
気分はどう?
あれ?おばあちゃんの手はどうしてこんなに大きいの?
それはね、展望をいっぱい掴むためだよ。
おばあちゃんの目はどうしてそんなに大きいの?
それはね、お前の捨て範囲をよーく見るためだよ。
お口はどうしてこんなに大きいの?
それはね、ロンというためだよ!
トヨトミ、おい!起きろ!トヨトミ!
マージャンやって途中で寝るやつがいるだかな。
お前、真面目にやる気あんのか?
いい加減にしねえと、血みると悪い。
夢か。
そうだ!
明智のあの捨て牌に騙されちゃいけない。
こいつら、みんな、獣みたいなやつだ。
ここは一発を避けて幻仏。
タンヤオメを目指して、一品斬りだ!
幻仏!
ローン!
明智の幻仏、オラに大当たり!
純ちゃん三色、ピンフードラドラ!
グータン
ついてねぇの
こうして赤ずかんちゃんは 狼たちに美味しく食べられましたとさ
めでたしめでたし
あけましておめでとう
みんなすてきなお正月迎えてる?
今年もアキナ、トヨタミ君と一緒に頑張っちゃうから、よろしくね!
次回、悪魔で悪魔!風につかんこ!
きっと見てね!
眠っちゃいや!
ご視聴ありがとうございました
つぼろうよ つかんと しあわせ つかもうぞ
ここは三面町どころ
ゆくべかんきゃん おくしぶそぼろ せひがはだ
すぼうにぃ ぼうば けんぼうにぃ やりぬいて
続いて、かつて飲み干すビールがうまい、スカッと、お酒は命がけ
スカッと、スカッと、ガキカメと、ダダダンの色
ご視聴ありがとうございました